quelle surprise c'est vraiment une très
très grosse surprise vous savez avant
les lancements bien souvent les marques
vous convier à ce qu'on appelle des
prêts bris fixe bien que vous êtes
invités pour découvrir les smartphones
en avant première c'est un très bref ils
pressent toute la presse l heure durant
une partie de la presse et regarde à
quoi vous ressemblez ces nouveaux
produits on vous informons vous disent
qu'ils vont faire et compagnie alors
quand on m'a parlé du zune phone 8 je me
suis dit les iphone 8 il paraît être
intéressant il va être probablement dans
la continuité du zen fanzhi du zen phone
7 avec cette caméra flip et c'est
presque tout le contraire presque parce
qu'il existe en fait deux smartphones
les iphone 8 dont je vais vous pareil
tout de suite et les iphone 8 flip qui
lui à la caméra flip qui est henri
ferait qu'une mise à jour du zèle phone
7 de l'année dernière avec des
améliorations mais qui n'a pas grande
révolution la vraie révolution s opère
ici elle se perd ma sur les iphone 8 est
ce une faune 8 c'est une petite
révolution parce qu'il ya un parti pris
qui va un peu à contre courant de ce qui
se passe sur le marché de ce qu'on
observe sur le marché mais qui par
contre répond à un vrai besoin des
consommateurs et une vraie demande du
consommateur et vous allez voir
in fine 8 il est petit mais costaud
[Musique]
ok on y va on rentre directement dans le
vif du sujet les iphone 8 c'est celui là
le zune phone 8 il est là et lezennes
phone 8 regarder il est tout petit on
est sur un écran en dessous de 6 pouces
c'est une vraie volonté de la part
d'asus d'aller là dessus pourquoi alors
on va prendre deux secondes pour se
faire un petit tour de l'analyse du
marché je sais c'est un peu dania mais
c'est important
regardez qu'est ce qu'on constate depuis
quelques temps on constate que les
smartphones font de plus en plus grands
les écrans sont de plus en plus grands
et en fleurs tout doucement avec les
écrans de 7 pouces on risque d'y arriver
en tout cas on s'en rapproche la norme
ses 6,5 pouces et un petit peu ce qu'on
trouve aujourd'hui
et l'idée que asus à y prendre un peu le
contrecoup rentrent sans les ans nous on
vous propose sur notre flagship on parle
bien du flagship on parle pas d'un
smartphone milieu de gamme on parle bien
du flagship et bien se positionne sur un
smartphone avec un écran inférieur à 6
pouces c'est très révélateur c'est
révélateur en fait de quoi c'est
révélateur que le marché est extrêmement
saturé de venir se positionner avec un
smartphone avec un écran 6 pouces voire
plus
et bien c'est souhaitant frontale avec
les autres là où il ya très peu de
places de disponibles asus est lucide et
sait très bien que il vaut mieux
s'adresser un petit peu moins de
personnes mais par contre vu hier par
guetté les bonnes chances de devenir
cibler les personnes qui cherchent des
produits spécifiques alors si vous
regardez aujourd'hui dans les
smartphones avec des écrans en dessous
de 6 pouces
il en existe sur du flagship vous n'avez
du côté de chez google
mais sur la grande majorité des facs
type les écrans sont grands de plus en
plus grands et très grands et souvent
avec des déclinaisons des gammes plus dé
gamme ultra et des games iessa là par
contre c'est vraiment autre chose on est
sur un petit écran dès sur un petit
format pourquoi puisque l'idée c'est
d'avoir un smartphone compact qu'on
puisse utiliser très facilement une main
qui puisse être entré très facilement
dans une poche qu'on puisse utiliser
sans galérer à aucun moment j'ai ma main
qui est là j'ai une main j'ai pas des
très grandes mains des regards des il
passe dans ma main il ne démord pas et
en plus de ça ils ont intégré un mode
qui est extrêmement malin et que je
trouve très très très bien vu et bien
c'est le mode à une main
vous venez glisser légèrement se remet
alors il faut venir l'activer et là vous
l'utilisez une main alors bon pas très
pratique parce qu'on n'y voit pas grand
chose grand chose non plus
mais malgré tout ça s'inscrit dans cette
logique là et avec une main vous
pilier l'avons venue en grand très
facile mais déjà si vous voulez utiliser
comme ça et bien vous pouvez l'utiliser
c'est pratique c'est simple et c'est
très bien vu de la part d'asus parce que
là il vient de répondre à un besoin du
marché qui est laissé vacant par
beaucoup de constructeurs
donc ça c'est très malin et je
m'attendais pas à ce que asus arrive
avec un petit smartphone petit mais
costaud avec ce iphone 8 pourquoi petit
mais costaud parce qu'à l'intérieur
vous avez tout ce qui est actuel vous
avez un snapdragon 888 vous pouvez
monter jusqu'à 16 giga de ram gddr5 et
jusqu'à 256 go de stockage en fs 3.0
comme vous dire que vous bénéficier des
dernières technologies de lecture
d'écriture de ram
le processeur le plus rapide processeur
5 g avec le modèle intégré directement
tous donc ça c'est vachement bien
donc ce smartphone il est super
intéressant et sur plein de points lors
des chasses éthiquement effectivement il
n'y a pas grande révolution par rapport
à ce qu'on voit sur le marché vous avez
ici une toute petite caméra qui va être
planqué ok ça marche on voit qu'on a un
haut parleur qui est un poil plus grand
ici qui délivrera un peu plus de
puissance on va en parler dans la partie
audio dans quelques instants sur le bas
et bien on a un tout petit menton
franchement c'est minuscule minuscule
sur le côté on va avoir des choses super
intéressantes juste là la regarder alors
le bouton de volume ok et là on a un
bouton qui est intéressant parce qu'il
est paramétrable c'est ce qu'asus
appelle le smart key qui vous servira
pour venir à l'allumer et pour
l'éteindre ça c'est très très simple
gagner évidemment mauvais petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui déverrouille
très très rapidement mais ce smart qui
il à ses fonctionnalités propres et vous
pouvez soutenir faire pas mal de choses
avec
si vous appuyez deux fois vous voyez
c'est marqué ici eh bien on va ouvrir
l'assistant google ok bon là on n'a rien
à lui demander vous pouvez également
venir personnaliser le bouton vous
cliquez là vous choisissez un accès
rapide vous choisissez si vous l'activez
désactiver le wifi ne pas déranger
captures d'écran il ya beaucoup de
possibilités ça c'est vachement bien
passer un appel
calculatrice et compagnies dont vous
voyez en appuyant deux fois dessus et
dont on peut faire quand même pas mal de
choses donc là c'est super bien ouvrir
des applications bref moi je trouve ça
super malin vous pouvez appuyer et
maintenir
de la même manière réveiller l'instant
google ou alors dire personnalisés ou
alors éteindre on va dire par exemple si
réveiller l'instinct google j'appuie et
je maintiens et j'attends et saab ouvre
effectivement on assiste en google donc
ça c'est vachement bien
c'est une fonctionnalité je trouve hyper
maligne parce qu'on vient une fois de
plus dans l'idée
la personnalisation c'est un truc que
j'aime beaucoup chez asus c'est qu'ils
ont une super expérience logiciel on l'a
au niveau de la batterie on peut venir
personnaliser son mode de charge pour le
rendre toujours plus intelligents
regardez vous avez plusieurs modes et si
vous avez le mode dynamique mode
dynamique cd performance optimiser son
utilisation au quotidien code haute
performance bombe alors on va venir
taper vraiment dedans durable pour aller
un peu plus loin ultra durable ou alors
carrément avancé pour répondre à tous
vos besoins et là vous choisissez ce que
vous voulez limites thermiques
performances du processeur performances
du gpu performance de la ram régler
automatiquement le réseau 5,6 bref vous
avez beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
possibilités vous pouvez venir vous
modifier directement ici donc ça s'est
super bien c'est pareil définir le taux
de rafraîchissement sur 60 r ton peu
poussée du soixantenaire dans ce mode là
vous avez toute la gestion de la
batterie
une économie d'énergie qui va être
programmée par exemple passer sur un
mode ultra économies d'énergie la nuit
donc ça s'est super bien c'est très
malin c'est bien géré et une fois de
plus à fonctionner ça dans le bon sens
dont cette expérience là je la trouve
vraiment très bien il ya un truc que je
trouve bien au niveau du design c'est
votre capteur d'empreintes digitales et
là je trouve positionné assez haut par
rapport aux smartphones vu qu'on a un
petit écran on trouve très facilement la
position et des verrous très rapidement
ça marche ça c'est hyper agréable à odos
on va retrouver un petit dôme at plutôt
sympa avec ici votre module photo lors
le module photo on pourrait se dire on
est serein flactif pourquoi est ce qu'on
a ici que deux caméras et pas 3d il a
fallu faire des choix comme on est sur
un smartphone qui est un peu petit et
bien on ne pouvait pas mettre tous à
l'intérieur
ici il manque un téléobjectif clairement
c'est un choix assumé par asus il ne
l'avait pas la place de mettre un
téléobjectif sans venir rogné sur
certains composants intérieurs et
notamment sur la taille de la batterie
n'ont pas voulu ils se sont dit c'est
plus important d'avoir une belle
autonomie une grande autonomie plutôt
qu'avoir un téléobjectif donc le choix a
été fait là dessus on regardera les
résultats photos dans quelques instants
voir si c'est intéressant et surtout un
smartphone qui font qu'une aire protégée
et c'est une vidéo qui réalise en
partenariat avec mon partenaire inochi
qui vous fabrique des coques super cool
pour venir protéger votre iphone 8 et
tous vos smartphones voulait prendre
votre iphone 8 vous le mettez dedans
vous l'aviez vous l'a serrée et tac vous
êtes protégé la sur les côtés il peut
donc trouver sur la face avant il peut
donc tombé sur le dos et sur le côté on
est tranquille tout va bien ça vous
permet d'avoir un smartphone
complètement protégé
et de profiter bien évidemment de votre
prise jack et de tout ce dont vous avez
besoin alors des coques série no chi il
y en a beaucoup dans tous les univers du
hunter hunter vous avez du fork lite
vous avez dû fairy tail vous avez dû
assassination classroom vous en avez de
tous les côtés les mêmes des coques
approuvé par la nasa et des cov dans
l'univers du sport ici notamment avec
les chicago bulls mais il ya également
des coqs dans l'univers de one piece qui
vont arriver des coques psg enfin des
coques de tous les côtés je vous invite
une fois de plus allez découvrir
l'univers de rhinau chiffres et le lien
que vous avez en bas dans la description
en plus vous profitez d'une remise de 5%
grâce aux codes greu 21 tout ça est
inscrit en bas et penser également bien
protégé la vente de smartphones grâce
aux impacts scream protector vous avez
une solution complète pour venir
protéger votre smartphone grâce aux
coques de rhinau chine et notamment ici
votre iphone 8 donc ça c'est bien une
fois de plus le lien est en bas dans la
description et pour la première fois
chez asus un smartphone qui est certifié
ip 65 ip68 données résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière
ici on est à la pointe de la technologie
je voulais dit tout à l'heure au niveau
des techno drame du processeur du
stockage mais en plus de ça vous avez du
wifi 6e alors le wifi 6e c'est pas pour
tout de suite en europe plutôt pour le
marché américain mais en tout cas on
voit qu'ici les une vraie volonté d'asus
de vous insérer les dernières
technologies et puis surtout un point
intéressant si vous avez une batterie de
4000 millions terreur et vous avez de la
couille chaz 4.0 de qualcomm parce que
oui comme on importe ce genre de
qualcomm on a les technologies de charge
de qualcomm et si c'est de l'art charge
30 watts avec une recharge qui est assez
particulière et qu'on retrouve chez
d'autres fabricants notamment chez oh
oui c'est à dire une recharge par le
centre imaginons tous d'un ce soit votre
batterie et bien au lieu de venir
broncher là il doit recharger petit
petit petit petit jusqu'à arriver à un
maximum on va charger par un milieu que
ça permet de recharger plus rapidement
des deux côtés effectivement va venir
charger beaucoup moins huit sauf que
vous arrivez au dessus de 80 % mais sur
le reste de la charge et dont il ya
quand même gagner en efficacité qui vous
permet de le recharger de 0 à 60 % en
seulement 25 minutes au niveau de la
charge et à une techno qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on retrouve
vraiment dans les écosystèmes d'asus on
l'a vu notamment sur le roquefort et on
le voit ici
et bien si vous pouvez venir paramétrer
votre charge à savoir que pour avoir une
charge constante vous le charger un
rythme lent pour protéger les cellules
de votre batterie elles ont besoin
d'être rechargée lentement pour aller
beaucoup plus loin donc ici vous
actionnez et vous venez de recharger
lentement ok ça c'est plutôt pas mal
on peut se dire également et bien moi je
leur charge et la nuit je vais faire une
recherche planifié je leur charge que
j'ai pas moins de cinq heures du matin 7
heures du matin il a eu 12 heures de
recharge sera largement dont et vous
pouvez vous dire eh bien on va dire
limiter la charge pour protéger la durée
de vie de batterie ton smartphone on
peut limiter la charge à 80 % ça me
permettra d'aller un peu plus loin dans
le temps - bien évidemment très
important c'est votre écran ici vous
avez un écran de 5,9 pouces avec un taux
de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz et là
on est en mode automatique vous pouvez
le laisser soit on s'en va y as tout le
temps soit 90 160 sert à rien mettez le
en automatique est ici en plus d'avoir
un taux d'échantillonnage tactile de 240
est donc pour toutes les parties de
gaming ça va être bien et ça va bien
répondre sans l'avant vont trouver un
corning gorilla glass victime d'un écran
qui certifiait lutter contre la lumière
bleue avec un pic de luminosité à 1110
un écran avec un deltae inférieur à 1 h
dr dispute bref on a un écran qui est
super bonne qualité un écran signée
samsung et de l'amoled alors maintenant
on va regarder la partie photo parce que
la partie photo c'est extrêmement
intéressant qu'est ce que nous a
proposée asus la boule valley on a un
double module photo n'ont pas été très
loin pas trop en attaque 4 on n'avait
pas de place on en a deux on pourrait se
dire aujourd'hui sur un flagship est-ce
qu'on attend un double module photo that
is the question
on va regarder ce qu'on a ici vous avez
un grand-angle de 64 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 1.8 c'est la sony mx 686
stabilisation optique avec un autofocus
avec la technologie 4 pixels en un pour
capter plus de lumière et notamment en
conditions de faible luminosité pour les
photos de nuit et vous monter jusqu'à
zone numérique à 8 grâce à lui on se
regarde ça dans quelques instants
et vous avez un ultra grand angle de 12
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 c'est la
sodie mx360 3 tandis que la caméra de
cette fille c'est une 12 mégapixels
autant ce smartphone je trouve vraiment
très bon en termes de performances au
niveau de la partie logicielle avec des
nuages je trouve très bonne sur
l'android on au quai ils marchent bien
mais autant au niveau de la photo je
trouve un peu en dessous je vous
montrerai je vous explique pourquoi
je trouve que c'est très saturé alors il
ya de la verdure effectivement mais
c'est très vert le vert est très poussif
et il ya un vrai traitement logiciel qui
va pousser la couleur est poussé à
saturation l'oreille un côté un peu
flatteur mais des fois un petit peu trop
ça c'est l'ultra grand angle et lorsque
je presse sur la caméra principale je
perds un tout petit point la saturation
je suis un peu moins sursaturé mais
quand même ça pousse un peu ça pousse un
peu sur le vert
je viens zoomer en x 2 eh bien écoutez
c'est pas mal je trouve que le
traitement est bien gérée d'un point de
vue logiciel dès que j'arrive ensuite os
x 10 c'est plus bon malgré tout la
gestion de la plage dynamique et très
bonne marche bien dans l'ensemble pas de
souci là-dessus ça ça me va bien
l'ultra grand temps d'une différence de
colo vous le voyez notamment en bas à
gauche ici sur ces fleurs là lorsque je
suis là elles sont un peu plus verte
la saturation vient toucher ça au
maximum dès qu'on se rapproche c'est pas
mal en x 200 x 5 on peut mais on voit
que l'algorithme cherche à compenser
avia lycée c'est un peu poussif sur le
côté du lissage on le voit au niveau des
bronches là il ya un côté pas très
naturel sur le traitement algorithmique
mais c'est vraiment pour venir compenser
un très clairement là dessus quand ya
pas de tels objectifs
et dès qu'on arrive au x 10 il plusieurs
fois ce problème alors comme je bouge
forcément chez moi ça tremble ça tranche
ça tremble mais là par contre voyez ça
bouge un peu
et c'est pas gg on continue ici c'est
sensiblement la même chose ça fonctionne
des compassions dutra grand temps on
perd un peu en précision mais c'est
normal là dessus mais c'est quand même
très très très saturé la même chose ici
c'est quand même bien bien un peu
poussif au niveau du haut niveau du
verre ultra grand angle très très saturé
par trop saturé le x 2 ça me va le x 5
citron le voit salissa regardez là au
niveau des arbres c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment poussif et dès qu'on
arrive aux faux 10 c'est normal ça c'est
par contre comme étant normal la même
chose ici
ultra grand-angle on se rapproche x 2 et
là on va au faux dit c'est pareil ça
bougeait et voilà ça c'est un peu
dommage quand même on continue ici
caméra principale pas mal on voit bien
les nuages ça me va bien même si à ce
côté un peu saturé flatteur sur la
caméra principale sur grand temps que ça
marche très bien l'actu des photos de
sortir de très bonne qualité c'est ok
l'ultra grand-angle on change une fois
de plus la colo on se rapproche en x 2
c'est pas mal ça me va bien et le
traitement vient soutenir ça sans en
faire trop et dès qu'on s'approche trop
mal c'est tout à fait la même
dès qu'on perd un peu de lumière il est
moindre il a un peu plus de mal il est
beaucoup plus imprécis il vient chercher
toujours à compenser à trop compenser et
assure booster la saturation et je
trouve pas ça dans le danemark voilà le
résultat est pas compétent la caméra de
celle fille quand elle est vraiment au
dec le résultat est correct ça n'aurait
donc je dirais que sur la photo le grand
angle ça me va bien
le foie de st-fabien l'ultra grand temps
que si on veut mais c'est quand même
trop
saturé et la caméra de celle ci va bien
le reste c'est quand même en dessous on
a donc un smartphone qui a une propos
qui est intéressante mais c'est vrai et
malgré tout on s'attendrait avec un
smartphone comme celui là sur un
flagship en tout cas avoir un
téléobjectif
on a même des zoom périscopique sur
certains tout ça et si on n'y a pas ici
vous restez sur le strict nécessaire
on a je dirais une configuration photos
qu'on retrouvait potentiellement sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme mais là et si
on est sur un flagship mais une fois de
plus il faut répondre au cahier des
charges petit smartphone pour des
besoins de format compact avec un écran
inférieur à 6 pouces voilà faut pas tout
mettre à l'intérieur à lorient 9 points
qui est intéressant ici c'est toute la
partie audio lors la partie audio je
sais pas si vous avez suivi notamment
sur le roquefort aujourd'hui à vue ce
travail avec d'irak
ça marche très bien sur l'iphone est ici
ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal on a malgré
tout une légère asymétrie
c'est une fois de plus que ce qu'on
retrouve beaucoup dans les différents
smartphones regarder je vous le fais
écouter ici vous allez vous en rendre
compte directement vous avez votre
opérateur principal qu'il situe la
deuxième haut-parleurs qui situent juste
là maintenant déjà des asymétries au
niveau de l'arrivée du signal ok là on
dort un squat il sera beaucoup plus
large
là un peu moins il ya un petit
déséquilibre on a vraiment si haut
parleurs de renforts sur le côté c'est
pas la meilleure expérience audio mais
se situe très clairement dans ce qu'on
retrouve sur l'ensemble des acteurs du
marché donc là dessus ils sont vraiment
dans les clous mais est par contre c'est
très rare sur un fake type
eh bien vous avez une prise jack je
crois qu'aujourd'hui dans les flagships
on a à sony qui vous le propose et on a
également ajusté leurs asus voiliers a
fait le choix de ne pas mettre de
tellabs le dis parce que le nombre de
places mais malgré tout dans cette fois
de préserver cette prise jack
donc ici vous avez lu ar l audio ça
c'est intéressant pour tous ceux qui
veulent écouter de l'eau de la musique
en haute définition et grâce à dirac
eh bien vous avez une expérience
personnalisable au niveau de l'aude où
l'on regarde et je vous montre ça vous
allez voir c'est vachement intéressant
vous avez un mode dynamique bonne
musique cinéma jeux est en dessous si
vous venez me chercher là vous avez un
équaliseur abandon classiquement montent
et baissent et les aigus directement ou
les graves là mais si vous souhaitez de
fer par band vous pouvez le faire donc
ça c'est vachement bien on peut aller
plus loin dans toutes les personnes qui
aiment écouter de la musique
avec une haute définition et qui veulent
venir paramétrer et bien vous pouvez le
faire donc ça c'est chouette
donc ça smartphones que ce soit
intéressant alors intéressant mais il
n'est pas fait pour tout le monde
clairement il n'est pas parfait il est
malgré tout bien et surtout au niveau du
tarif vous allez voir aller tout est là
dessus au niveau du tarif le asus iphone
8 il ya plusieurs config 828 on est à
699 euros pour un flagship il est bien
positionnée 8 256 on monte au niveau du
tarif 749 euros tandis que seize plus
256 on est à 819 euros à voir en
fonction des besoins que vous aurez déjà
828 paraît quand même pas mal il est
extrêmement bien positionnée à 699 euros
il ya des pré-commandes du 12 au 31 mai
vous avez moins de 100 euros sur la
version 828 vous le tombe à 599 euros
alors c'est en quantité limitée il ya
500 pièces que vous allez pouvoir
retrouver donc si vous souhaitez d'abord
à profiter du meilleur tarif est bien un
petit peu moins de 600 euros
vous avez un smartphone compact avec un
écran de 5,9 poussée de l'amoled qui
marche bien qui est réactive qui marche
très bien avec beaucoup de performance
qui n'est pas parfait au niveau de la
photo parce qu'il lui manquait quelques
petits éléments mais qui malgré tout
fonctionne quand même relativement bien
c'est très chouette avec de la recharge
rapide c'est un truc que j'aime bien moi
c'est vraiment une config que jamais je
trouve que asus a fait un choix connu là
dessus ils ont osé le faire ils ont pris
le parti de se dire eh bien on va mettre
à profit tout le savoir-faire qu'on a ce
partenariat avec direct pour l'audio
pour avoir du très très bonne audio le
fait d'avoir quoi le comme de l'autre
côté sur le processeur le fait
d'intégrer les meilleures technologies
est d'abord de la kul charge quatre de
qualcomm avec un bloc de charge rapide
le fait de proposer une très bonne
expérience logiciel également là dessus
pour vous permettre de venir prendre la
main sur les équaliseur pour pouvoir
venir choisir comment vous voulez
charger vos smartphones de pouvoir tout
choisir ce smartphone l'a clairement ils
m'ont pas en vendre autant que pourrait
faire certains concurrents parce qu'il
n'est pas destiné à tout le monde
mais malgré tout ils viennent se
positionner dans un segment sur lequel y
est la place sur lequel il ya une
demande et sur lequel est effectivement
il n'y a pas foule de concurrents donc
moi je trouve ça intéressant
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser happer par le
sinn fein 8,2 asus sur le smartphone
avec un écran inférieur à 6 pouces
marquer ma tout ça bien évidemment en
bas en commentaire et quant à nous
on se retrouve très vite pour continuer
à parler plec mais également appareils
de l'us des bisous dabo a très vite ciao